amber heard says she still loves johnny
depp so what's next a lot to process
welcome to entertainment tonight kevin
and michelle are off and let's dive
right in because there is so much to
unpack from amber's new bombshell
revelations
i love him i loved him with all my heart
i just want johnny to leave me alone
no bad feelings or ill will towards him
at all he picked up the decanter
and hurled it at my
head amber's feelings about johnny well
they're complicated she says she still
has a deep love despite her repeated
claims that he abused her i was
heartbroken
scared
the actress also told the today show
she's afraid of what depp might do next
i'm scared
that
every step that i take
will present another opportunity for
this sort of uh silencing
and amber doubled down on what was one
of the hottest debates of the trial
pledged versus donated sitting here
today
you have not donated the seven million
dollars donated now pledged donated the
seven million dollars divorce settlement
to charity
i use pledge and donation
synonymous with one another
i made a pledge
and
that pledge
is made over time by its nature
legal expert julie rendellman says she
understands amber's desire to speak out
but
in a sense amber heard's not really
doing herself any favors the same people
who didn't believe her all along will
continue not to believe her
amber's full interview airs friday night
on dateline so what's next for the
actress how do you see your future now
i get to be a mom like full time amber's
team denied a report she was being
recast in aquaman 2 calling the rumor
inaccurate insensitive and slightly
insane the story is interesting
considering the fact that during the
trial studio exec walter hamada
testified amber's role was actually
pretty small the movie was always
pitched as a buddy comedy between jason
momoa and patrick wilson they were
always the two
co-leads of the movie they basically
took a bunch out of my role they just
removed a bunch
so much keeps happening i don't think
we'll really know the outcome of that
part until aquaman 2 hits the
you